[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby
and today i wanted to show you some
really incredible games
from norway chess norway chess i believe
uh ben simon and i were discussing is
the first
you know super invitational tournament
to be back since the pandemic playing
over the board
in person chess of course there were
some high level players in the
bundesliga but this
is this is it you know uh six of the
world's best players all in norway right
now
duking it out on the chessboard and as
you can see from the title
the theme tonight is actually going to
be one of defense
of course the art of attack is a very
famous
chess book one of the best chess books
of all time but really what separates
today's top players
from top players of the past is their
ability to defend
positions their ability to have a
slightly weak king or a slightly bad
position
and defend it make something good out of
it and turn it around and get the full
point
so we're going to look at some examples
of that here today
to start off i have a game between
levonaronian and aryantari
and this is a game i was actually
following live of course there is some
wonderful commentary being provided by
kramnik
um who is like what better chess player
can you ask for for commentary and
judith polgar as well another superstar
commentator
and i thought they had a lot of
interesting thoughts about this game and
analyzing it afterwards i actually found
that uh you know maybe some things were
slightly different from what they were
saying so let's jump into it and take a
look
we had e4 by aronian e5 and we go down
the depths of the royal lopez theory a6
back it up knight f6 castles bishop b7
rookie 1 b5 bishop b3
not super interested in getting into a
huge uh opening discussion here
but ariana tari chooses the marshall
gambits
or martial attack however you want to
call it i think it's called the martial
attack not the gambit
but either way it is a gambit of a pawn
by black
black breaks in the center with d5 white
can capture this pawn
but now unfortunately for black this e
pawn has been left behind
with the activation of white's rook here
on e1
black takes back on e5 white captures on
e5
we see c6 by black securing this knight
on the d5 square
and then the normal moves here are d4
and d3
and that's about as deep as my you know
theoretical knowledge on the marshall
ghost
but levon aronian actually chose a bit
of a sideline the third most popular
move of rookie one
just removing this rook from any kind of
threats
any potential tactics on e5 of course
black
is anticipated or white is anticipating
a bishop coming to d6 with pressure on
the king's side and so now this move
just won't come with tempo
so bishop d6 is actually played anyways
white can now transpose to the main
stuff by playing d4 d3
but levon aronian chooses g3 instead
and already the defensive task for white
has begun i'm sure we are still
well within both players prep here but i
want to highlight a bit what exactly
levonaronian is doing
so of course of course in the marshall
attack white is a pawn
to the good but in exchange black is
getting very very rapid development
and is able to create some nasty threats
on the white king's side
thanks to all of his pieces uh minor
pieces and queen
sort of bearing down on this half of the
board so what is lavon doing right off
the bat
well he's setting up a strong color
complex
and this is sort of an idea that can
show up in many many different positions
lavonne is going to make his stand on
the dark
squares so why the dark squares well for
one
he's able to limit this dark squared
bishop uh pretty effectively by playing
g3
but in addition to that he's also
limiting this knight this knight is no
longer
going to freely hop around into the
king's side
compare this if lavon played a horrible
move like h3
with h3 you know you might think a lot
of the same things are being
accomplished right
we are sort of negating this bishop by
removing its target from the h2 square
we're even preventing this bishop from
hopping into some dangerous squares
and we're not making all those light
squared weaknesses around the king
however i do think this move is pretty
substantially worse
now there is always going to be a knight
f4 knight f4 hop to worry about
the queen can come to h4 and black is
going to be very happy to sacrifice this
bishop
at some correct moment and just play for
the win on the king's side
so dark squares are the squares that the
lawn chooses
to fight for in this case because it
negates both of these minor pieces by
black a really cool defensive idea
ariantari continues his development with
the move bishop f5
and levon finally pushes the d pawn out
to d4
in this case now we see an interesting
move
by aryanthari the theoretical move is
apparently queen
to d7 getting behind this bishop and
play might continue something like this
black just getting the remaining pieces
into play and
going for some kind of attack on these
light squares forcing this queen
even further away from the king over to
the queen side in the game though
ariantari goes for queen
f6 with some slightly different ideas
and this isn't
you know a novelty technically i think
this has been played once or twice
before
but it is um a perfectly reasonable move
by black bringing the queen into the
attack
connecting the rooks and preparing for
the future
now how do you guys think lavonne should
continue in
this position i want you guys to try and
come up with some kind
of line some kind of defensive variation
for lavon
and when i say that i mean try to find a
plan for these three pieces
these three pieces remain undeveloped
and you sort of need to figure out
how you can best place them to defend
the king and try and consolidate your
position
so take a few minutes here or i'm not
going to wait a few minutes take a few
moments
if you want to take a few minutes go
ahead and pause the video
and try to figure out where these pieces
really belong
in order to keep white safe what should
lavon be doing here
also yeah hello hello to everyone in the
chat thank you all for joining me
tonight
hello to chess king bobert collins dan
thorsen matheo mateo rather
hello
um chess king likes the move bishop c2
which is a pretty interesting idea
trying to get rid of the light squared
bishop and his reasoning
is that the light squares are weak and
so he's trying to bring this guy back
into play
or at least get rid of the light squared
bishop any other ideas in the chat
hello to aryan ariane we are looking at
a game
by your namesake here our antari
okay someone said bishop g4 i'm not sure
i understand that
is the g4 square it's difficult for
white to play bishop g4
queen f3 is an idea says uh chess king
once again
and so uh i'm going to be asking you
guys to be thinking
rather far ahead here so there's one
very specific reason why i don't like
the move bishop c2
and that reason is this bishop is
actually potentially going to serve an
important defensive role
from the f3 square number one it's
offering some
chances for counter play by pressuring
this knight on d5
and number two it is actually going to
be relevant that this bishop is eyeing
this king
from a distance why is that well it will
become very very clear a little bit
later on
but one reason is that a very powerful
idea for black
to try and break down uh white's
defensive blockade on the dark squares
is potentially to push this f pawn
forward activating this rook on
f8 and chopping on the g3 square to uh
sort of break down this blockade
and obviously if this f pawn were to
move
then this bishop would be looking very
very nice on the b3 square
forcing almost black to spend an extra
tempo to remove the king
from these kinds of threats so all of
that is to say
we're not so interested in moving this
bishop that we've already developed
when it could very well serve a useful
purpose on b3
this bishop is already in the game
already developed it's already
pressuring one of black's potential
attackers and indirectly the black king
so it is actually pretty technically
wrong to be moving this bishop right now
as for these pieces well obviously you
can't really come to f4 you can't really
come to g5
and so the move bishop e3 should
definitely be on your mind for white and
this is what levon starts with
as for coming up with a plan well i
think it's pretty clear that this knight
should reroute over to the king side in
some manner well whether this knight
comes to
f1 f3 or maybe even e4 a little bit more
of an advanced
uh an advanced square for the knight
pressuring the black pieces
is still unclear but at the very least
we can get these pieces out with bishop
e3 knight d2
and then chess king's idea of queen f3
is going to be very very important here
uh so how did this take place in the
game well levon simple enough for him
just plays bishop e3 black tries
queen g6 and now we do see knight d2
uh now bishop g4 i think would be
playable
uh immediately but white would be
potentially happy to go queen c2
and queen h5 and now
white is successfully sort of taking
over this e4 square
and black is going to have to shuffle
back and forth a little bit so instead
we see
black play the preparatory move rook a
to e8
taking a little bit more control over
this e4 square before trying to take
over
and go for these check mating ideas on
g2
now how to continue well avon plays the
third move we were discussing queen
f3 just bringing the queen to the
defense of the king
how does the game continue now well
aryanthari plays very naturally playing
bishop g4
forcing this queen now to a rather
awkward square either g2 or h1
uh queen g2 is lavon's choice
and now we see queen h5 and now i would
like you guys to stop and think about
what
white should do from this position white
has sort of achieved many of his opening
goals he's gotten all of his pieces off
the back row
you could argue that they are actually
fully developed in fact
and now lavonne needs to make some
decisions
about how to handle this middle game so
what ideas are coming to mind for you
what ideas spring to mind here
and yeah the chat is actually mentioning
some interesting uh
roots routes roots for this night
uh including potentially coming to the
f3 square to try and break down this
knight
and again this is another reason why
it's so nice to have this bishop here on
b3 for the moment
not to say we're never going to bring it
back to c2 or d1 but for the moment it
does provide some nice pressure
on d5 and keep this idea in mind because
it might actually show up a little bit
later in the game
so there is one key move in the marshall
attack for white that everybody should
hopefully be
familiar with right now white is
defending the king with a
number of pieces but this rook sitting
here on a1
is you know quite quite a sorry piece
and in fact
this is the one piece what you can
really effectively use
to get meaningful counter play
especially after the move rook
a to e8 so of course the move for
counter play the natural move in the
marshall that
you should be familiar with if you play
this opening is the move a4
and so how is this related to defending
the white king right we're talking about
the art of defense in this lecture
so what does a4 have to do with anything
well a4
is how white achieves counter play in
this
opening and that's why this move is is
so critical
whenever you're playing you know
defensively whenever you're on the back
foot that does not mean
you have to play entirely passively one
very effective way
of defending is by attacking you know if
your opponent is dealing with threats on
the other side of the board
you may be able to distract some of
these attacking pieces or gain more
material gain more advantages
on that other side of the board which
will
of course distract from the fact that
you have to defend your king a little
bit or your position might be a little
bit weak
on the other side so i think a4 would be
a great move here
but levon actually holds off on playing
a4
he plays another move which was rather
controversial
on the broadcast this is about where i
was tuning in uh listening to of course
uh the incredible players vladimir
kramnik and judith polgar
and they had a lot to say about lavon's
next move
so what does levon play lavon plays the
move h4
which is a very very interesting idea
um of course the main point in this move
is that it is gaining control albeit
temporarily
of the h3 square why does this matter so
much well
if you play something like a4
you know later on in the game you might
have to contend with bishop h3
and you know this queen on h1 is not so
happy
and if this queen ever you know is
completely evicted
uh from the light squares let's say you
know a bad move like knight f1 were to
be played then already stuff like bishop
f3 and this queen is actually going to
be trapped
white has some tactical ideas still in
this position
but you know the queen being trapped
obviously not
ideal and threats of queen h3 are going
to be coming
as well so h4 both gives this queen some
space
and takes back control of one of these
light squares
around the white king now can anybody
tell me what the obvious downside of the
move
h4 is what is the downside here
because at first glance it does just
seem to technically improve
white's position on the king's side
right it's negating many many many
of black's threats but it is not without
consequence
so chess king says it's a bit of a hook
which is one
one idea that black often has whenever
white is pushing a pawn like this in
front of the king but i don't think it's
the most relevant one here
if we were to use the h-pawn as a hook
that would involve playing the move g5
which is admittedly rather difficult to
manufacture here
yeah i the a lot many people in the chat
are saying this idea of g5
but i'm not so sure this is the easiest
move to to get off and by the way
g5 may actually be helping white defend
if this h file
opens and this queen comes to h1 you
might find it's a useful
defensive idea for white to be able to
trade the queens in many cases
rather than an attacking idea for black
so the other idea being mentioned in the
chat is i think the more relevant one
here
and that is that the g3 pawn is now very
very weak
and so lavon is now going to have to
contend with tactics against this g3
pawn
for the rest of the game and this is why
kramnik and polgar
did not have such nice things to say
about this move h4 they thought perhaps
lavon
is taking some risks against aryantari
who wasn't having the best tournament
still isn't
and is the lowest rated player in the
field
uh but on the other hand maybe lavon has
some ideas here
so after this move h4 uh ariantari
actually does find a very very
interesting move here right to take
advantage of the fact
that g3 is slightly weakened you know
taking on e3
is actually a pretty bad idea because
it's a bit too simple right for the
moment you're not actually winning
anything
on g3 and you're sort of giving white
the center
uh and at the same time you're
clarifying the situation for white which
is not really what black is interested
in doing like it's trying to make things
more complicated
so arjan manages to find this really
incredible move
bishop e2 and this is a pretty nasty
move here
the point is you just shove this bishop
in the way of the rook and now there is
a very serious threat of knight takes e3
lavon's pretty much only move here is to
play knight f1
so he does defending this bishop on
e3 and of course if bishop takes f1
wherever be played
i think king takes f1 is going to be the
idea
and everything is still solid here for
uh for white
so after knight f1 black comes up with
this move
rook to e6 and i think already uh this
is aryantari perhaps playing a bit too
loosely
in the position so i think the time is
right here
for black to try to play the move bishop
f3 and the point now
is uh white will either have to go
bishop d1
and trade off some pieces and
what do you think black's idea might be
if he gets this light squared bishop off
the board can anybody tell me
uh also by the way white's only other
option here
is to sort of go queen h2 which is just
not going to be a pleasant move in this
case for white so bishop d1 really
should be played
and then can anybody tell me a useful
idea for black
in this particular position here
and yes uh someone in the chat has it
uh the idea f uh of f5 is going to be
quite strong
we removed this bishop for white that
was offering counter play
against the black king and now f5 is
another very useful way
to attack the dark squares after h4 has
been played
and so lavon might be facing a little
bit of pressure here as well
not saying he has a bad position by any
means but this would be
a useful way for black to sort of find
counter play
in the position um instead of that
though we see rookie six
and now levonironian comes up with a
pretty nice move of bishop d2
right black was going to bring this rook
to e8 and sort of renew the threats
against the bishop on
e3 so the simple move bishop d2
is now preparing to trade some pieces
along the e file
as well as introduce ideas of you
guessed it knight e3
that was being mentioned earlier on in
the lecture rook fe-8
was the follow-up here for black
and now levonironian finally breaks
through with a4
the classic idea for counter play in the
marshall we do finally see
bishop f3 levon aronian inserts a trait
of rooks
white is black is not interested in
taking the queen when he would lose
two rooks and a bishop for the queen
here
so rick takes back on e6 queen
h3 for levon and then after bishop g4
queen h2
is where levon puts his queen to avoid a
repetition of moves
with the bishop moving back and forth
now aryan plays this
a simple move h6 giving the king a
flight square
and levon can finally play a b a b
and now knight e3 and suddenly
things are are beginning to look rather
unfortunate for
uh aryan tari here uh he's very much on
the back foot now you know at first
glance it looked as though
black was the one with all of the play
but now black has to be very very
careful to not be
worse in this position why is that well
we'll see very quickly in the game
what happens and how this position can
can go south at a moment's notice so who
thinks they can find
the only move to sort of keep black in
the game at this point
like really only has one move that's uh
that keeps the game going here
it's really only one idea that works out
it's not the idea of f5 f5 would lose
the game right
now 5 was good earlier because we got
rid of this bishop on
b3 with the bishop still here i think
you might find
you are running into some tactical
issues on the d5 square
not f5 here
no not c5 either i think c5 is is losing
this piece right
got to be careful yeah bishop f3 well
you guys are playing like 26 33 rated
player aryan tari so not too bad but
bishop f3 unfortunately is not it
believe it or not i think black's best
try is to actually capture this knight
on
e3 why is that well it's because
black has total domination over the
light squares
if this bishop and this knight come off
the board
so after bishop takes c6 bishop takes e6
bishop takes e3
here black can play for counter play
based solely on the fact that the light
squares are
totally totally absent for white queen
e2 is coming as well
and black is going to have a lot of
active play on these light squares and
can try
to keep the game going a bit for example
something like queen g2
bishop d5 queen h3
um queen b2 and
now uh black is of course getting a lot
of play
against these queen side pawns and like
i said has
enough threats against the white king to
uh to sort of sort of stay in the game
here by the way if queen f1
then i think queen g4 is going to be a
good idea
and now white has to be careful not to
be worse for example if you play some
nothing move like this
bishop takes g3 is going to come and
like i said plenty of threats in the
position here
for black still remain so knight takes
e3 would have been an interesting idea
to sort of keep black in the game with
plenty of threats
just removing all of white's pieces that
can defend the light squares
and then playing for that kind of
domination instead though the move
bishop f3 comes on the board
and now unfortunately for aryantari
lavon aronian is able to break free
on these light squares how does he do so
well now this knight is controlling a
very very important
g4 square and allows for the move queen
h3
and now it is just too late for
oriantari to stay in the game
white has the active rook on a1 white's
queen is going to be able to escape
out through f5 or g4
and uh you know the threats are sort of
dissipating now
for orientary and at the end of the day
he's just down a pawn it's tough in the
game to stop
bishop f5 uh arientari played bishop e4
and by the way it's too little too late
to try knight takes e3
now after takes here there is of course
a queen takes with
check and this is going to be a pretty
substantial difference in the position
so bishop e4 was tried but now queen g4
and white has broken free
the queens come off the board and now
it's levonironian's game
to win f5 still comes on the board but
now a very very clever move
by lavonne is the move knight e5 and
this is a
a pretty unusual tactic actually uh i
should say this one was
one of the more interesting tactics so
can anybody tell me why black can't just
simply win a pawn on the e5 square
why can't black win a pawn
what's wrong with black winning upon for
free
free pawn on e5
so not quite f3 f3 is important
but not to start with
so yeah believe it or not after take on
e5
which is actually played in the game
intake on e5 which is not played in the
game
the move rookie one is a pin that cannot
be broken
um it's pretty highly unusual to see
you know all of these pieces sort of
flounder in a situation like this where
there's no way to break the pin with a
full tempo
for black but there's just no way to
break the pin
rookie 7 is only fake defending this
rook because this king
is still on g8 and f3 would win a piece
you cannot go rookie 6 and retreat the
bishop because there's simply no
retreating squares
there's no way to attack this bishop for
a turn you can't like go
c5 c4 you're just too late here because
i'm attacking this
knight and even this and again there's
just nothing to do
and yeah this would be winning a piece
for white it's it's a rather unusual
tactic i wanted to highlight this one
but
after takes takes arientari is of course
strong enough to see those tactics
and plays king f8 instead but now f4
and it is definitely levon aronian's
game to win now
rookie 7 was played in the game uh and
levon ironian
finds a really nice idea which is to
take on d5
if bishop takes d5 were to be played
then uh there is another tactic here for
levon and c4
when you will be losing the exchange so
c takes d5 must be played and then it is
a highly highly unusual situation
where after a few more moves bishop e3
rook c7
stopping bishop c5 rick a5
bishop d3 uh bishop d4 rather
rook c6 king f2 h5
and after h5 believe it or not white is
essentially playing
with an extra piece what do i mean by
that
i mean white is going to be trying to
win
on these three ranks using this pawn
and after the move h5 this bishop cannot
legally
interact with any of these squares this
bishop is stuck
on this half of the board and usually we
don't talk about a piece being entombed
when it can move on over half the board
but this bishop is essentially just
entombed here and it's it's a pretty
crazy idea
but white is totally winning because
this bishop is essentially
not not on the board for black it's it's
a really unique
kind of uh construction here uh king e3
was played bishop c4
uh rook a3 was levon aronian's idea with
now some threats
of of going b3 rook g6 is played b3 does
show up on the board
no time to take this when both of your
pieces would be hanging
so bishop f1 this is a czech king e8
bishop b4 and again this cannot be
captured because this time
this uh king f2 move is a fork
so bishop g2 is played now king d4
and now this piece you know could
potentially be captured but you're just
losing way too much time
e6 is forced to mate so rook c6 is
played instead
rick a7 g6 rookie 7 check
king d8 e6 rook c7
or f7 and here uh aryantari
resigns the game it's actually like mate
in 13 or something according to
stockfish it's
it's just totally busted again white's
up a piece
it's it's a pretty pretty nice idea here
by lavon
so it went from you know very decent
position you know plenty of attacking
chances
to to bad to worse for aryantari
very very quickly there so i want to
take a look back at those few critical
moments where levon aronian really
turned around this game
so uh i'm going to say this move h4
was a really nice idea by lavonne
of course if black plays very very
accurately here black is doing fine you
can't just refute the martial attack
this easily but this h4 idea gives this
queen a little bit of space
and really does slow down black's attack
on the light squares
so keep an eye out for uh you know sort
of strange looking moves like h4
as long as you understand the downsides
of these moves and make sure you have
good responses to moves like bishop e2
moves like f5 moves like g5 then
this move is sort of just playable and
it's just an improvement
in white's position after that
this idea of bishop d2 and 93 is a very
nice
reroute for white white made his claim
on the dark squares that's where he's
taking his stand and then he breaks free
by controlling a few light squares to
activate his pieces
get the queens off the board and then
win the game and from there
aryantari sort of just collapses and
levon iranian is able to win a very nice
game
once again a4 critical idea let's see
one
set of rooks come off the board then
takes on b5
knight e3 queen h3 and the game
is over levon aronian sort of just
crushing it here by the way don't think
you can get away with the move of g6
controlling this square g4 traps your
queen
by the way side note kind of important
side note
any questions on this game before we
move on to a second one
where did tari go wrong his position i
think is
technically fine uh until
um let's see here i think rook feat
might might be a bit of a misstep i
think here
is sort of aryan's last chance to go
with us a simple move like h6
keeping this rook back on f8 to defend
this pawn and keep ideas
of f5 alive and yes slow move like h6
i i think is fine here for black in the
position to be honest though
i i'm not convinced i understand the
position well enough
to uh to to suggest meaningful
improvements
for black i think this was just a very
very well played game by
levon aronian and it's it's tough when
that happens
also some other ideas might might just
be to
start chasing this queen around a little
bit earlier and
force white to go to some awkward square
if he does want the game to continue
and then from here maybe stuff like rook
g6 maybe stuff like rookie 8 here
um and it's just going to be a game
definitely though the last mistake i
should say
is this move bishop e4 uh this move is
the
the losing move quote unquote i think
though you know ari antari's position is
is already pretty tough sorry i think
bishop bishop f3 not bishop e4
is the losing move here this idea of
sacrificing this exchange
i think is perfectly reasonable still
for black and i think black is still in
the game
okay let us move
along
so i hate to do it to the guy but we're
going to take another look
at a game from aryanthari this time
he had to go up against the world
champion uh his countryman
magnus carlson uh and like i said it
just hasn't been aryan's tournament
so far and uh he he's playing some
really active really interesting chess
but again these world-class players
uh where they really really excel
compared to you know the world-class
players of old
is their ability to defend positions and
that's exactly what happens here
against magnus carlsen but let's go
ahead and take a look we have ariana
playing e4
magnus carlsen going for the move c5
knight f3
knight c6 we get a sicilian d4 takes
takes knight f6 by magnus
knight c3 d6 uh
bishop g5 by white bishop d7
by magnus and again this is just some
some heavy
heavy sicilian theory here this is the
richter rouser
by the world champion queen d2
and now a6 is definitely not the most
common move by magnus
just controlling the b5 square we have
queen side castles
and now e6 by magnus
now f4 comes on the board and we are
back in some very well known
uh very very well known theory i believe
uh bishop e7
breaking the pin for magnus knight back
to f3
is the idea for arianatari regaining
some control over the e5 square
b5 launches the counter attack on the
queen side for magnus
we have a take on f6 and now g takes f6
helps magnus build a nice little
fortress in the middle of the board
we see king b1 queen b6 getting active
and this is still by the way just some
some heavy heavy theoretical opening
stuff i don't want to get too deep into
it
f5 queen side castles
and the move bishop d3 by aryan is sort
of the first move that is not
you know the the mainline stuff here so
what is going on in this position well
we have a situation
where black's position is very very
compact
but of course there is some airiness
some space
around his king and some threats of
white breaking things open in the center
of the board
so once again it's going to be the
higher rated player on the back foot in
this case trying to defend a position
but not necessarily you know playing for
a draw or anything just
trying to defend and wait for the right
moment to uh to sort of counter
counter-strike counter-punch fight back
um so in this case magnus plays a very
simple improving move
king b8 and that's something that you'll
see quite quite often in these positions
with queen side castle
castling you just get the king off of
the c file
and to a safer square on b8 now the move
knight e2
comes on the board by aryan atari
so what is aryan planning well it's
pretty clear
that he's trying to come to f4 and
increase his pressure
over the light squares in the black
center
if you can force a move like e5 he'll be
very very happy when this knight
is suddenly landing on the square d5
so how does magnus respond to this well
he actually just plays the move
bishop c8 he's keeping his position
compact for the moment
keeping all his squares defended and
just allowing his pieces to to breathe a
little bit
knight f4 comes on the board and then a
very nice defensive idea here
for magnus comes on the board what do
you guys think what's this defensive
idea
for magnus carlsen what to do
yeah it's still the richter rouser even
with a6 on the board
even with a6 although i i mean sometimes
i think you can transpose between
openings
in this case
uh chess king says undeveloping in
regards to bishop c8 i assume
no uh i think it's redeveloping more
like right
this bishop's important role is to
defend e6 and it does that from the
starting square on c8
and it's not undeveloping because the
rooks are still connected and in fact
it's sort of a developing move for the
rook on d8 it allows it
to examine this pawn on d6 a little bit
so yeah what magnus carlsen is
interested uh is actually a couple
things here
number one he wants to break free on the
d file with d5 you guys are exactly
right number two this idea of knight e5
is going to be really really critical
for black
with this setup he has really good
control over the e5 square
and he needs a central square for one of
his pieces in order to fight back
against this army that is sort of
staring him down
so 95 is the move that magnus plays
now of course black is white is really
not interested in allowing this
structure
when black would control sort of every
central square
very very thoroughly and fight bet or
push back the white pieces
and so the move bishop e2 comes on the
board
now magnus continues very naturally with
the move d5 and i think practically
this is a a fantastic way of playing
this
is in a sense uh kind of upon sacrifice
meaning that black is not going to be
real not going to be able to recapture
on the d5 square
but the idea is not so much to you know
get a big center
the idea is to allow black's pieces to
breathe
that's what's really important in this
position and that's what magnus carlsen
is going for here even if it looks like
you are the one with less space on the
defensive back foot
having less space doesn't actually
matter unless your pieces
are awkward what do i mean by that well
the advantage of space comes in giving
your opponent a cramped position
a position where they don't have enough
room to effectively use their pieces
so if you can effectively use your
pieces it almost doesn't even matter how
little space you have
so after d5 this bishop can come to c5
this bishop has
ideas of coming to b7 at a future date
and all of black's pieces are going to
be effectively in the game
so black spatial disadvantage no longer
matters
and this is a great idea when you are on
the defensive back foot the one with
less space
if you can find jobs for your pieces you
should
not be much worse at all e takes d5
played by arientari
sort of the the very natural idea here
uh and here magnus carlsen takes on f5
which is
maybe not the greatest move in the world
but
it is kind of funny to see three f-pawns
with the two knights you know sort of
hiding behind them here
and magnus for the moment is regaining
his pawn why isn't this move the best
well now knight d4 is eyeing some really
crucial squares in the position
for white and also for black of course
uh bishop c5 comes on the board by
magnus this is the idea of d5 to get the
pieces into the game
rook hf1 rook h e eights
magnus like i said just trying to
effectively utilize all of his pieces
to sort of negate the space disadvantage
uh our antare plays the move
a3 here and now i would like you guys to
try and find
magnus carlsen's next move right
um you sort of achieved what you set out
to achieve with your your d5 break you
got this bishop to
to c5 and now you need to go about um
trying to defend this position i'm not
going to lie to you here magnus has
a pretty tough position in this case i
think he is a bit worse
but how do you play such such a position
how do you play such a position let's
find some ideas for
magnus
edward lee in the chat says he's had
quadrupled pawns before but it didn't
end well
fair enough i remember playing a game
where there were um
i think five f pawns
if you count both sides i think white
had doubled pawns on the f file
and uh i was playing black and i had
tripled pawns on the f file it was a
pretty fun game
[Music]
bobber collins says knight g7 i don't
know if bobert has suggested a legal
move yet tonight
but i wish him the best in finding one
nightmare says b4
and yeah b4 is a really good idea for
black in many cases obviously i don't
think we should play it immediately
but this is going to be a nice idea not
necessarily
you know a traditionally defensive idea
but it's another one of those ideas
where you're going for counter play
and with counter play you can sort of
change the story away from one
of you playing a purely defensive
passive role to one of you playing a
more attacking role so b4 is an idea to
keep in mind but i don't think we should
do it just yet
uh yeah and steve north has another
great idea in knight c4 these are really
two critical ideas for black to gain
some counter play
knight c4 is always going to be a threat
that white is going to have to contend
with
a threat that hits white's queen
threatens knight e3 and threatens
sacrifices
on the you know quote unquote queen side
where white's king is
uh all all at once of course this is
another move that cannot quite be done
immediately
due to threats of knight c6 but these
are two great ideas to keep in mind
later in the game
why isn't the black king safety in
question it is that's why this is a
lecture on defense
yeah knight g6 is is headed in the wrong
direction unfortunately this knight is
probably black's best piece this knight
on e5 is very strongly placed
controlling many many light squares and
threatening jumps like knight c4
not really interested in trying to trade
this guy off you know meekly asking for
trades is not always the best way
to defend so now that we see these two
ideas
for counter play for black that's how
you can start to arrive at the next
defensive moves that magnus plays
if you don't see these ideas magnus's
next moves probably make very very
little sense
but if you do see these ideas then you
might arrive at the move
king a8 which is what magnus plays in
the game what's the point of king a8s
well magnus is preparing for knight c4
with the opening of the b
file or b4 also with the opening of the
b
file in mind it's also stepping out of
knight c6 with
check and allowing him a little bit more
freedom to move these pieces around
so king a8 a great practical move in
this case
now ariane starts doing some strange
things he plays the move h3
which i think is just way too slow here
i i don't think h3 is going to be very
relevant to the game
and to be honest with you i still don't
quite understand what his idea was
if it was just stopping knight g4 if it
was you know considering some g4 move
later on
i really don't understand this move but
that's what was played in the game
and magnus's next move while uh you know
the computer doesn't quite like it i
think practically it is
perfect he plays the move bishop back to
d7 sort of
a strange looking maneuver if you are
just thumbing through the game right you
know the bishop comes to d7
comes back to c8 comes back to d7 but
of course the idea makes a ton of sense
when you keep in mind
magnus's two moves for counter play he's
preemptively
over defending the c6 square preparing
to launch his own counter-attack against
aryan's king
and this is just great play i think
practically from the world champion
and now aryan unfortunately makes the
mistake
that permanently loses the advantage for
white
he goes knight h5 which again is a step
in the wrong direction he's trying to
play against these tripled pawns
that black has over here but at the end
of the day he should have been trying to
kill the guy
with this weak king with so much space
around it so
chat see if you guys can find uh guys
and girls
can find the best continuation here for
white how do you prove an advantage in
this position
yeah maybe you can attribute h3 to uh to
some nerves
trying to play a bit safe but in the end
at the end of the day if you give the
world champion enough time
he's going to be able to come up with an
idea
so there are a lot of ideas in the chat
i'm not sure i'm in love with bishop f3
because that does really increase the
power of knight c4
bishop is actually an important
defensive piece for white
but yes the idea is going to be pushing
this pawn to d6
in some manner you can either do it
immediately we can start with a move
like queen c3
but i like d6 immediately why is this
move so strong
well because this pawn was actually sort
of playing for black it was keeping
the knight out of d5 and once this pawn
is no longer on d5
knight d5 is a really tough threat to
meet for the world champion
uh black would love to capture this pawn
for free but now this idea of queen c3
does come into play and this rook is
suddenly looking at the black
queen this bishop on b on c5 is no
longer really so comfortable black can
fight for some counter play with the
move b4
but after takes takes queen b3
here it does just become very very
difficult for black to make moves if you
try to remove the queen from the file
bishop takes a6 as an idea with the
loose bishop on b4
if you try to play bishop c8 white can
start snagging some pawns
and here um you know
black is going to have a tough time in
this position this is just
a pretty bad position now for magnus
carlson
if the gamer to continue knight d5 is
probably a really great idea
to follow up with again taking advantage
of this
loose piece over here something like
bishop
f5 even knight fte3 and
white is sort of just dominating the
position this king is going to be
permanently weak and if this knight ever
moves bishop f3
is going to be a great idea for the
moment if this bishop were to land here
i think
black would be happy to take it off the
board f6 is hanging
everything is just falling here for
magnus so d6 is a really crucial
attacking idea
that aryantari unfortunately missed in
the game would have been
a nice find here notably though after
takes if you don't see this idea of
queen c3
i think black is once again you know
starting to become better here
queen c3 is a really important idea to
find and maybe this is what ariane
missed
in the game though we do see knight h5
and now how to continue
continue with black you know white has
played a bit slowly
now is your chance chance to uh to
counter punch
to break free from your slightly
defensive slightly passive position
see if you guys can find the point
what is the point here for magnus
carlsen
so yeah we already talked about the two
ideas that magnus has
one is knight c4 one is b4
and it's a question of deciding which
one looks better in this case it
is going to be knight c4 that is the
more powerful move um
white is essentially forced to capture
this piece
if you don't capture this piece and move
the queen for example
you know rookie three it's just it's
it's pretty bad queen
queen back here this piece is hanging
it's it's tough
so captures this forced and this is what
happens in the game
and here uh magnus has a good position
as we'll see
but why not b4 well it turns out uh
white has a nice defensive idea here of
number one
just taking number two going knight to
b3
if takes on a3 then believe it or not
queen a5
and white is going to be in this game
black kind of has to trade these queens
off
and now with queens off the board these
f pawns are going to
start to be you know felt a little bit
more by black these are going to be
pretty key weaknesses in this endgame uh
i don't think black is much worse here
at all there's still play against the
white king even with queens off the
board
but b4 would give white this opportunity
to get rid of these queens before
anything too terrible happens
knight c4 played instead bishop c4 bc4
and aryantari tried to move queen to c3
now though rook b8 increases the
pressure for black the move king a8
coming in useful once again
rook f3 was the move by aryan but
unfortunately after this move
the game is sort of lost see if you can
find the
stunning move that magnus plays here to
uh to win the game
this move is a bit of a bit of a
scorcher
bit of a scorcher here not knight takes
f6
now he takes f6 unfortunately is still
defended
and yeah aryan gutlaw has the answer
maybe he's seen the game before but um
of course
the answer is rookie one
maybe he found this himself but i i
would be impressed rookie one is a
pretty incredible move
um and this move does just win the game
it is not in a sacrifice of a full rook
but just in exchange
because this knight is a key defender
well this knight is under defended both
of the pieces that can take the rook on
e1
defend the knight on d4 and that is
magnus's idea
or take c1 was played in the game now
bishop takes d4
queen b4 is the only try now for
white and the stunning follow-up is
actually queen c7
a retreating move that activates this
rook and
from here on out magnus is just winning
d6 was tried by aryan but now queen c6
queen a5 uh here apparently the best was
rook takes but magnus plays bishop takes
and this is good enough
king a2 to step out of the discovery but
now bishop back to e5
these threats are in the position so
rook b1 was played
takes takes and now magnus just takes on
d6
and the threats against this king are
still here
and these two bishops are going to rake
through the white
position king c1 was played now queen d4
keeps up the pressure with threats of
now queen g1
uh aryan took this pawn with check but
after king b8
believe it or not there are no more
checks with black defending all of these
squares
c3 is what aryantari played but now
queen g1 check
and the end is near takes on g2 king e3
f4 check knight takes f4 uh bishop takes
f4
or takes f4 queen g3 check rick f3
queenie one check king d4 queen e5 check
king takes c4 queen e4 check king c5
queen takes f3
king d6 bishop c8 and resigns
as magnus carlsen is now up a piece um
did magnus see all that ahead of time
maybe not
but he understood that the king should
not really be surviving
on b1 after this idea of rookie one and
he was
correct in that sense black was always
winning the game after this move
rookie won um really really impressive
game here
by magnus carlson i have to say
so what went wrong this game for aryan
atari well let's take a look
let's take a look somewhere around here
i would argue that especially after the
move e takes f5
white has a pretty pleasant position
right he has all these ideas in the
center of the board
and black's pawns are looking a little
bit sad over here
on uh on the f file
i think here knight d4 is perfectly fine
rick hf1 is fine
uh rookie 8 a3 is even fine trying to
slow down ideas of b4
um king a8 h3 i would argue
is just a mistake h3 and then knight h5
and after two bad moves
the game is in magnus carlson's control
so
what should he be doing instead of h3
and knight h5 let's try and come up with
some ideas in this
position what can be done here
why does white play a3 let's
think about it for a second why does
white play
a3 to be honest with you a3 is one of
those ideas
that is sometimes good um and many many
times bad
and it's so tough to tell the difference
i think in this case
the point is that uh
after b4 a takes b4 is going to be a
good response in many cases
for white because the idea of c3 to
follow up with
allows white to sort of take control
over all these squares on the queen side
i think this is probably what our antare
was going for um
yes b4 still opens files for
black but white is able to take back
control of many of these important
squares
after the move b4 is played so i think
this is why a3 and i think this
isn't a bad idea but it does sort of
increase the power of knight c4 i should
say with
especially when after pawn takes pawn c3
is going to be such a huge threat
in every position now so maybe a3 is a
little committal but
i think it's fine but what can aryan do
now instead of
h3 and knight h5 two moves which i think
are very
very far beside the point
uh noam says what went wrong was that he
was playing against the world champion
yeah that's definitely part of the
problem definitely part of the problem
yeah queen c7 is is pretty tricky says
says harry and
i tend to agree
so yeah again this this bishop f3 move
isn't so good
isn't so good these threats are are
definitely looming in the position
and at worst case if black doesn't ever
have knight c4 you know taking this
bishop
isn't exactly a bad deal for black
either
stuff like bishop b7 to follow and black
can fight back on the light squares
so bishop h5 i i don't really agree with
i don't think white should be going for
play against these f pawns here
i think white should be trying to
resolve the situation on
the queen side and going after the black
king a little bit i think this is where
black
is going to have the most success so
uh what does that actually look like in
practice well i think this move b4
is actually well worth considering here
for ayantari
it sort of forces the issue with black's
pieces this bishop doesn't really want
to treat back
retreat back to a square like f8 and
sort of go back to being passive
so if black is forced to take here white
can then get the queens off
and in any sort of endgame position
these pawns are
going to become very very weak very very
quickly and i think white is
significantly
significantly better here so i think b4
would have been a really clear-cut
practical way to continue the game
and if magnus does play a move like
bishop e7 or bishop f8 for example
i think uh white is just going to get a
better version of
uh the position that that he did have
right you can
you can continue now with the move like
queen to c3
and these ideas of knight c4 are sort of
very much
being dealt with b4 is now an illegal
move so that idea is dealt with
a5 is hard to manufacture with a weak b
pawn
and i think white is you know getting
getting a better grip on the position
than he would have otherwise so i really
like this idea of b4 practically
of course there are many many moves in
the position that white can try
and most of them keep the advantage but
here especially now after bishop d7
arya needed to find these moves in order
to preserve his advantage
okay any questions on either of these
games before we call it a day here
any questions on either of these games
yeah kind of anonymous it's less about
going for
trades and more about
understanding that magnus's threats are
knight c4
and b4 and realizing that you know
black doesn't really have the option of
going for trades it's not like you offer
trades and then hope your opponent takes
them
it's about using the fact that trades
are good for you to force your opponent
to play sub-optimal moves
like bishop f8 that's why b4 is so good
all right no questions well then the
uh next lecture is starting momentarily
it is going to be
on uh as chess king is saying in the
chat end games from the norway chess
tournament there were some really really
interesting end games and i
am very excited to walk you guys through
them there's some
great technique being shown here at this
tournament and it is really nice i
should say to find
uh to see all of these players doing
what they do best over the board chess
the high quality games that we have not
seen for uh for some time now
so hopefully you guys go check it out
the link is in the chat if you're
watching the video version thank you so
much for joining me
as always my name is caleb denby and i
will see you next time
you